it's a new year and people are making
resolutions to lose weight and get in
shape for many folks those resolutions
are pretty tough to keep up Santa Monica
City Council is now considering adding
an extra hurdle on the road to wellness
regulating outdoor fitness after
neighborhood complaints about there
being too much exercise in the parks the
council is set to vote on how to
regulate fitness instructors this spring
Palisades Park is a public park and
doing commercial enterprise in a public
park or a public facility really should
have regulations around it the
recommendation is to limit private
trainers for compensation so any classes
over to people they're trying to ban it
and also they're trying to impose an
additional 15% fee for all the trainers
so we're paying for business license
permit insurance and we're paying city
taxes every year so on top of that we
got to pay a extra 15% sake Hong has
been training clients here for over a
decade
I tried his bootcamp to see what all the
fuss was about yeah there were a lot of
people working out here but they hardly
seem disruptive my booty is gonna write
you a handwritten letter and it's not
gonna feel good tomorrow morning you
know we haven't had any complaints and
you know I have you know lifelong
clients that I've been training for many
many years so they're trying to take
that away do you live around here
yeah are they ever too loud or
disruptive never so you see them often
now do you know they're trying to ban
these outdoor classes no that's crazy
what's the park full and the stores are
here everything is close by it's very
convenient you know people are open and
friendly and nice and it's a park it's
not a museum this is what people should
be doing with their outdoor spaces how
long have you been working with honky
seven years and how do you feel about
the council in Santa Monica trying to
shut down these outdoor fitness classes
I think it's a big mistake you're gonna
be 84 next month January 7 said we'll be
84 yes I will be this is what keeps me
young doing
hongki's boot camp he doesn't cut up the
grass he doesn't make noise he doesn't
have loud music I didn't notice any
problems with a grass either but there
has been some concern about physical
damage to the parks damage to the turf
and other
amenities in the park attaching exercise
equipment to the trees light poles and
various other amenities in the parks
now if the city planned to channel the
15% of the trainer's hard-earned profits
into repairing the so-called damage I
still wouldn't like it but I'd
understand it yet this does not seem to
be the case it would go into the general
fund we don't have specific funds that
we put revenue in so how do you feel
about the city of Santa Monica reaching
and taking 15% of your profits well I'm
not really happy about it they should
try to really work with small businesses
like me instead of trying to make it
harder for me to survive you would think
that the government would want people
working out absolutely
right now we have 2/3 of Americans who
are overweight exercising freely is not
the issue any of these regulations would
not preclude an individual or a group of
friends from going to the park and
taking a jog running a commercial
business in our parks is is really what
the issue is but this is a public park
it's for the public the City Council
should not get to decide what activities
are allowed regardless of whether or not
money is changing hands do you think
it'll force some of the trainers who are
cooperating to go out of business it'll
definitely be tougher for people you
know other trainers to survive what
would happen to some of your clients if
they stopped working out